we went camping this weekend there was
no lovemaking at the campsite why not oh
there's a sign that says no lovemaking
big answer anyway last night I'm kind of
standing around the bedroom behaving
myself until maybe there's an opening
you know right and um and I got in the
bed and I thought you know what maybe we
should try one of Ronnie sex tips but I
said there are no more of Ronnie sex
tips Ronnie doesn't give Sam steps
anymore and now I don't know what to do
whole thing was over in four minutes
really well yeah why are you not doing
the sex tips anymore if you run out no
well what's going on I guess they just
gave it a rest for a while
it's rested too long if you had to give
Jimmy a new sex tip do you have one he
went outside the cabin go ahead he went
went for a little walk
right and take you know taking out his
dick
yeah log and get his log shut up shot a
picture right and since it tamale oh
right yeah but I did it weirdly uh well
I'm not gonna criticize your sex tips
because they are excellent but I don't
think that would be that exciting for
her oh really why not no how do you know
I hope you don't think that would be a
neuron to seeing a picture of your [ __ ]
at a certain point you know that that
girls don't want to see a picture of
your [ __ ]